sie alle wollen auf und davon
christine schönbächler und ihr mann
hermann sie ziehen mit ihren kindern
regie und natascha nach kanada anja
kinski und claude wegmann wollen sich in
italien eine existenz aufbauen mit dabei
ist kino der trüffel und anni kuhn und
orlando stamm geben ihrer jungen liebe
ein neues zuhause auf bali bauen sie
eine ferienanlage jennifer wettstein
jemand ali und söhnchen sven versprechen
sich in peru eine bessere zukunft in
lima sollen ihre träume wahr werden
[Musik]
das wetter in lima ist trüb und passt
zum anlass heute wird ali wettstein
seine familie für drei monate verlassen
um in der schweiz zu arbeiten
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die letzten wochen hatte aly damit
verbracht in lima das eigene zuhause für
seine familie einzurichten
[Musik]
in italien kämpften claude und anja mit
den tücken neuer gartengeräte
während anni und orlando in bali die
götter um elektrizität für die
hotelanlage baten
hermann hat in kanada eine erste
kostprobe seines holzfäller könnens
abgeliefert
um zusammen mit seiner familie
bekanntschaft mit einem bären gemacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sich nach hause fliegen kann
ein halbes jahr ist es her dass ali mit
seiner familie aus bern nach lima
ausgewandert ist
aus alledem haustechnik installateur
wurde in der heimat seiner frau jenny
ali der gastwirt heute wird ali
wettstein allein in die schweiz
zurückkehren
dort wird der drei monate auf seinen
gelernten beruf arbeiten und so die
familienkasse aufbessern
[Musik]
hinschauen nächster woche läuft dorthin
gab es ist ein großes ziel für mich ist
meine unterstützung ist dass man axel
und alle im natürlich war der alles
allein
und das ist ja statt inniger umarmungen
und tröstende worte haben jenny und ali
stress manchmal hält sich das leben
nicht an die spielregeln schaffen
markenmacher die windsurfer suche nach
nachwuchs
[Musik]
ja
auch an einigen mitmenschen aus
und dann klappt es ja doch noch drei
monate lang werden sven und jenny auf
ihre gage verzichten müssen
[Musik]
mag
da wird sicher
[Musik]
viel glück
manni traum und das war dann geht das ja
klar das sieht echt schweiz und das
werden sie wirklich besser nur genau
insulin als kindergartenkind an schweiz
im moment ja klar aber das macht die
ganze team sondern sie selber sei hier
glücklich aussah aber nicht wo sie
stehen
mit davos kommen
[Musik]
in italien herrscht eitel sonnenschein
und trotzdem gibt es zwischen glut
wegmann anja kinski und deren schwester
nina ein bisschen dicke luft aber
[Musik]
missbrauch einladen wie können wir ja
hochlegen
so wie du
die gabel ist eingeladen doch claude ist
immer noch ein bisschen übellaunig und
das mit gutem grund
die frauen brauchen misst für ihren
garten und claude der den lieferwagen
bald weiter verkaufen möchte befürchtet
dass der wagen dreckig wird und stinkt
[Applaus]
wir wollen jetzt ist wohl nur dass jetzt
ein bisschen blöd ist wir haben ja eine
mistgabel dabei und hier bräuchte man
eher eine schaufel weil es ist nicht mit
stroh sondern sägespäne
jetzt werde ich mal fragen ob irgendwo
in schubkarren bekommen und und eine
schaufel beziehungsweise werden
wahrscheinlich mit dem auto bei mir von
amerikanischen könnte doch jetzt der
typischen auch das mit ihrem schauen
dass man das dann irgendwie die gardinen
in den fugen
warum
[Applaus]
zurück geht ja mach doch mal was ja
schon wieder vor
das heu
nina kind gelebt seit ein paar jahren in
los angeles und arbeitet dort als
fitnesstrainerin für ein paar wochen ist
sie in der region der marke in italien
zu besuch
zusammen mit ihrer schwester anja und
claude renoviert sie ein
heruntergekommenes landgut in zwei
jahren soll daraus ein agriturismo mit
vielen tieren entstehen
[Musik]
wollen wir auf jeden fall irgendwann
realisieren dass ein paar eigene pferde
haben russland zu haben das gelände ist
ist wunderschön
arabella als angehauen war jetzt endlich
wie kino mit futter ist sie wieder
zurück zu locken
naja und die schaufeln strecken auch
bloß stimmung hat sich inzwischen
gebessert
denn seine befürchtungen haben sich
nicht bewahrheitet
[Musik]
und sie stücke mit alpha group kommen
in kanada lädt die sonne zum arbeiten
und spielen im garten und zum nachdenken
wieso mein gesteuert
sie war so mein geschmack ist wird sich
das als mister he
jetzt fast philosophisch sage ich die
welt via elfmeter beste mittel zugeführt
werden
als sich herrmann und christine
schönbächler kennenlernten verband sie
der traum vom leben in der kanadischen
wildnis heute viele jahre später leben
sie ihn gemeinsam mit ihren zwei kindern
regie und natascha
vor einem halben jahr sind die
schönbächlers aus dem kanton bern
hierher gezogen
[Musik]
das haben die zahl die schönbächlers
sind glücklich in ihrem haus das sie
zusammen mit neun hektaren land für
250000 franken gekauft haben
[Musik]
unterdessen machte das ist das motto
kostet 50 ob er nur so umgebaut
[Musik]
seit einem halben jahr können anni kuhn
und orlando stamm in bali miterleben wie
ihr kleines paradies entsteht fast
genauso lange hat es gedauert bis sie
endlich ans stromnetz angeschlossen
wurden
es kommt was sie herstellen
es kommt wasser durch jeweils gut da
der vermessungsingenieur und die
hauswirtschaftslehrerin sind seit
viereinhalb jahren ein paar
ihre liebe hat sie dazu beflügelt in
bali einen neuanfang zu machen
[Musik]
die pläne haben
aber was du bist doch das muss aber sie
belaufen
das dicke buch also damit beträgt ich
hatte wunderbare menschen
das funktioniert ganz italiens idylle
hat alle versöhnt mutter ute genießt die
sonne
trüffel und gino dem schatten nottwil
leute mit muskelkraft und hammer ans
werk gehen während im garten der mist
verteilt ist und sich die schwestern um
die setzlinge kümmern können
nach jahren der kopfarbeit der ideen
entwicklungen und der konzepte genießt
der werber claude wegmann die arbeiten
auf seinem landgasthof hier löst er
probleme nicht in langwierigen sitzungen
sondern mit dem hammer
[Applaus]
man muss aufpassen dass man den stier
nicht an fast wie wurdest du ein
bisschen auflockert und man darf die so
wenig wie möglich stören weil die noch
sehr empfindlich sind also darf man sie
nicht quetschen nicht pressen
die müssen ganz locker einfacher sprache
eingesetzt das wäre ein bisschen mehr es
ist nichts ernstes perfekt es ist das
erste mal seit ihrer kindheit dass tanja
und nina sich so nahe stehen muss man
sich wieder irgendwie aneinander
gewöhnen oder so die das ganze team
sozusagen
aber stopp denn eigentlich recht gut und
jeder bringt irgendwas mit dina hat er
gerade in amerika noch ein kurs gemacht
wie man so immer gemüse auf diese art
und weise anbaut und so ergänzt
dann ganz gut das gute ist daran dass
man sich als schwester ebenso gut könnte
[Musik]
ich finde es lustig ich sehe ganz auf
meine schwester zum beispiel gesten die
mich an meinen vater erinnern
es ist mir vorher gar nicht aufgefallen
das glas voll gefüllt werden wenn sie
ist ein glas voll gefüllt bekommen
möchte einfach so wie sie denn ab dem
finger zeigt also kleine sachen einfach
kleine sachen die mich an meinen vater
erinnern das ist schön
sino kom kom kom kom ihr kino ist mir
gar nicht bewusst gewesen so viele rad
gekauft haben anja hat ihren job in der
schweiz sicherheitshalber noch nicht
aufgegeben
in einigen tagen wird sie deshalb wie
ihre schwester aus italien abreisen und
claude alleine lassen
das muss jetzt vorerst der claude
fliegen was
in gewisser weise ein bisschen riskant
ist weil er eigentlich nicht der große
salat und gemüse isst er ist sie stiegen
in säcke mit david kommen
[Musik]
jenny will sich ein neues standbein
schaffen im replay einer der größten
warenhausketten perus stellt sie ihre
neueste geschäftsidee vor
hier hinein
ja bereits in der schweiz hatte sie
damit begonnen gipsabdrücke der boj von
schwangeren frauen zu machen
inzwischen sind hände und füße von
kleinkindern dazu gekommen
the masses neun monate heißt ihre neu
gegründete firma ein kleines werbung zu
haben bei ihnen wenn ich jedoch nichts
bezahlen auch wenn ich keine abdruck
mache auch einige neue stunde hier bin
und meine flyer zu geben das ist schon
viel
dafür verzichtet jenny sogar darauf alle
zum flughafen zu fahren das wollte
eigentlich alis schwager matteo
übernehmen
doch dessen wagen läuft nicht
ja
[Musik]
und als wäre die situation nicht schon
aufregend genug stellt ali fest dass er
seine vielfliegerkarte nicht mehr im
portemonnaie hat ali bittet seine
schwiegermutter jenny anzurufen nach der
karte zu fragen
bis zum abflug bleibt nicht mehr viel
zeit
[Musik]
registriert
einfach zu machen
[Musik]
jennys mutter sarah beschwört ihren
schwiegersohn mehrfach er solle es ein
bisschen ruhiger nehmen
doch der weiß dass in zwei stunden sein
flugzeug geht
nimmt es ruhig mein lieber alles ruhig
alles wird gut vertrauen auf den herrn
und teams ruhig jetzt muss ich wirklich
los schöne reise
aber gewiss ein letzter blick zurück
erst in drei monaten wird ali wieder in
peru sein
[Musik]
in den wäldern kanadas will hermann
schönbächler nicht mehr und nicht
weniger als sein lebenswerk vollbringen
er träumt von einer nachhaltigen
waldwirtschaft so wie er das in der
schweiz gelernt hat doch das ist nicht
immer einfach denn die arbeitsweise in
den ausgedehnten wäldern nordamerikas
ist anders als er das gewohnt ist
natürlich würde lieber mit motorsäge
schaffen ob er flüchtete dann mit
zweifeln und ja
[Musik]
mit schwerem gerät muss hermann
weitläufige räumungsarbeiten vornehmen
das kann gefährlich sein denn hier in
kanada ist er im gegensatz zur schweiz
oft allein im wald
[Musik]
sollte hermann etwas zustoßen wäre weit
und breit niemand der das mitkriegt der
sicherheitscheck für alle schaffen somit
zu jeder folge stunden im auto wird bis
nicht mehr ordentlich war der konnte
sich an betriebe stehen stirn möchte
oder wenn ich aufbruch die irgendwie
frank hoffmann daniel christine und die
kinder erkunden den wald rund ums haus
ihre nachbarn wollen in diesen tagen ein
ganz seltenes tier erspäht haben einen
weißen schwarzbären einen kerl wie ihn
die einheimischen nennen
doch heute sind nur spuren der tiere zu
entdecken den zweijährigen richtig
interessiert das jedoch weniger viel
lieber spielt er mit pocket dem neuesten
mitglied der familie schönbächler
[Musik]
lustigerweise unheimlich
[Applaus]
anni kuhn und orlando stamm bietet sich
heute ein besonderes schauspiel am tag
vor der einweihungsfeier ihres
ferienresorts lernen sie ein weiteres
stück balinesischer kultur kennen
in einem hinterhof werden unmengen von
opfergaben für die feuer zubereitet 800
franken lassen sich die schweizer das
fest kosten viel geld dafür wird ihre
hotelanlage gesegnet und das halbe dorf
verköstigt
das so in aurich bezieht was wichtig ist
oft erwähnt dass das der zeremonie fern
und mehrheit der anteile vollständig
oder konzerne und an anderer stelle sind
sehr sehr häufig und wenn das nicht wir
statt fing das ziemlich sicher abstellen
der platz und niemand in bali würde es
verstehen wenn die schweizer nicht schon
heute ein wenig vom huhn und vom gepäck
probieren würden einwirken gehören der
vorwurf stimmt steht für die silber
aluminium damit sehen und den
bloßstellen über den abschluss der 7
nicht mit nach anne und orlando haben
von allem gekostet und so ihr gesicht
gewahrt jetzt wartet ein arg der typisch
balinesische paul schnaps
[Musik]
in italien ist claude wegmann nun allein
einzig gino wird ihm während der
nächsten wochen gesellschaft leisten
claude wird die zeit ohne seine
partnerin anja kind geht dazu nutzen die
maurerarbeiten vorzunehmen
das ist langweilig werden könnte diese
gefahr besteht nicht
seit der schweizer und die deutsche das
land gut gekauft haben wird ihnen mehr
und mehr bewusst wie baufällig die
gebäude zum teil wirklich sind heute ist
der hühnerstall an der reihe
oder besser das gebäude in dem später
einmal die hühner untergebracht werden
sollen hat er die melodie früheren
kannst du nichts taugen wenig glaube ich
auch dass man durchsetzen kriegen zum
teil des einsteigens local das heißt zum
teil einer ganzen nation hat nämlich mal
eingestochen
[Musik]
meistens entweder gesicht ermittler
schneider
der werkzeugbau ich dann langsam
vollständig aber wissenschaft von grünen
zweig also irgendwo mit dem handschuh
für den es nicht und dann tatsächlich
juni um ein gebäude sind oder das andere
hauptgebäude der dominikanerinnen von
der hinterteile gegen die 100 jährig und
diese zweite letzten 50 oder 80 genutzt
wurde also hast jetzt nur selbst im weg
schnitt dankt den straßen alle richten
damit gerechnet dass die zahl noch vor
wochen zusätzlich gibt aber wir haben ja
theoretisch sind leute so überrascht auf
den rechtsakt an haiders kommentieren
öffneten so wie vor offenen ausgangs auf
spielzeug oder größtenteils versorgen
das heißt mit anderen entwicklungsregion
ausgaben ebenso strom und wahnsinnig war
somit zahlen aber sie haben hoffen sie
nicht so viel anders ist aber viele
investitionen fast 30 um trauer aus auch
ein agriturismo wird nicht an einem tag
erbaut
doch kommt claude seien kaum tag für tag
und stein für stein näher
david villa irgendwann mit parkplätzen
start und doch eines guten zeuge ohne
dass man irgendwie zu fühlen aber das
gar nicht so verstehen sich auch relativ
groß
[Musik]
der tag im warenhaus war für jenny
vielversprechend sie will ihr geschäft
mit den abdrücken in alice abwesenheit
vorantreiben
der sitzt im flugzeug zurück in die
schweiz muss noch scharfe muss nicht
traurig sein wenn es lange zeit aber
wenn man viel zu tun hat wird wirklich
schnell vorbei für die nächsten drei
monate ist jenny neben ihrem job auch
alleinerziehende mutter
ja wie viele alleinerziehende montag
gibt es war dass sie haben das mit
seinen bildern zusammen was steht denn
so verspielen
danach kam
hermann schönbächler ist ein mann mit
prinzipien zu den gewohnheiten des
holzfällers gehört es dass er sich den
bart abschneidet bands sommer wird
[Musik]
hier
ja
[Musik]
du brauchst dich möglich
wie kann der feind auf das was kommt zu
ihm
so
ja
ganz anders in der schweiz wird ali
wettstein von seiner mutter franziska
erwartet
ein halbes jahr hat die mutter ihren
sohn nicht gesehen doch jetzt wird er
für die nächsten drei monate bei ihr
wohnen
[Musik]
ja
wir sitzen hier das ist das genie schön
mitgenommen
aber die themen der aria dritte liga ist
braucht es ist dass das ist das andere
zu verkaufen
und hoffentlich wieder aus und da ist ja
noch ist dieses niveau im prinzip spot
ina mittagessen getroffen ist sowie das
da wenigstens im prinzip die familie ist
li na ja für mich sind sie da
das wäre das wenn die sind natürlich in
lima deiner musik darzubieten liter im
beruf banker also wenn man kann
[Musik]
in bali ist bereits früher morgen heute
wollten anni und orlando eigentlich ihr
ferien resort eröffnen
doch weil vieles noch nicht fertig ist
mussten sie diesen termin verschieben
die längst geplante einweihungszeremonie
findet trotzdem statt
orlando erkundigt sich balkon an seinem
einheimischen geschäftspartner nach dem
ablauf der zeremonie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der anfang der feier ist
vielversprechend
aber reichen all diese rituale und die
üppigen opfergaben auch wirklich um alle
bösen geister aus der ferienanlage zu
vertreiben
die antwort auf diese frage nächste
woche dann tauchen auch die ersten
touristen im ferienparadies auf
[Musik]
in italien ist es endlich soweit anja
und claude kaufen die ersten tiere
in bern krampft ali auf dem bau während
jenny mit sven in peru allein ist
hermann kämpft um den titel des besten
holzfällers der schweiz und auch seine
liebsten müssen in kanada ohne papa
auskommen
dies und mehr in der nächsten folge von
auf und davon
[Musik]